l'hiver arrive en même temps que leur
confinement la bergerie nationale de
rambouillet s'adapte mais la difficulté
et surtout ailleurs cet été la
sécheresse a été très importante
sécheresse a débuté dès le printemps
donc on a vraiment eu une période très
difficile jusqu'à la fin du mois de
septembre
parce que le il a plu moins de 50 mm
entre le mois d'avril et le mois de août
septembre donc ça a vraiment été très
difficile alors lé directeur de
l'exploitation profit du réseau actuel
pour laisser les animaux au maximum
dehors et profiter de la pousse
automnale pendant l'hiver les animaux
qui peuvent rester au pâturage resteront
au pâturage en fonction des conditions
météorologiques et les animaux qui ont
des phases de mise bas ou qui ne peuvent
plus aller au pâturage entreront dans
les étables dans les bergeries deux
troupeaux principaux sont présents sur
l'exploitation 70 vaches laitières et
400 brebis
l'hiver est aussi l'occasion de faire
quelques travaux les autres chantiers de
l'hiver ça va être la remise en état des
clôtures et tous les chantiers ont à
dire autour de l'entretien des bâtiments
etc
une boutique est présente sur
l'exploitation pour vendre les produits
de la ferme et des produits locaux
pendant le premier confinement un drive
avaient été ouverts mais cette fois ils
fonctionnent normalement
contrairement au printemps le parc du
château reste ouvert donc les gens
peuvent venir circuler et venir jusqu'au
magasin
donc nous avons laissé le magasin ouvert
du mercredi au dimanche de 14 heures à
18 heures avec un respect strict des
mesures sanitaires donc le port du
masque obligatoire un sens de
circulation dans le magasin et une
limite aussi du nombre de personnes
pouvant être à l'intérieur du magasin
les clients eux sont ravis que le
magasin reste ouvert il n'y a plus rien
tout est fermé
hélas une nourriture de qualité moi
j'habite à rambouillet donc je suis
souvent venu traîner ici
avec mon petit fils et oui oui je viens
tous les deux jours à peu prend c'est
très bien j'ai envie de tout acheter
voilà j'attends la fin du confinement
profiter de la restauration le gérant a
vu de nouveaux clients venir pendant le
premier confinement grâce au drive
fermiers depuis ils sont toujours
présents et les produits qui se vendent
le plus ici ce sont les produits
laitiers et les colis de viande